big scandal up in Canada new photos have  surfaced of Canadian Prime Minister  Justin Trudeau in blackface yeah  as a result Trudeau has been dropped  from the cast of Senate live he's gone  rid of him he will not be appearing  anymore what else is going on Beto  O'Rourke says he has a plan to legalize  marijuana yeah yeah unfortunately he  can't remember it it's no idea where he  put it  I just wants to take a nap yeah  everyone's okay I want to stress that  everyone's okay but yesterday you may  have heard a Delta flight had to make an  emergency landing after it dropped  thirty thousand feet in two minutes yeah  Delta gave every passenger a free  round-trip ticket and a new pair of  pants  I find that reaction weird too cuz they  [ __ ] themselves what's wrong with you  people I like to say a joke and then  blame the audience for liking it for  enjoying it yeah yeah that's what I like  to do